the gyro can experience when you see
someone reveling in the power of being a
cult leader like I guarantee you when
that guy in Waco what the [ __ ] was his
name Koresh correct David Koresh I
guarantee you when when he was on the
news and talking about how they'll never
give up I gave girls were probably
beaten down his door trying to get in
that cult the crazier and the nuttier
and the more more apocalyptic your
message the more people that want to
join it's weird and they they just they
just don't have the ability to discern
oh this is not a good idea
this guy really doesn't have his head on
straight this guy might be [ __ ]
completely crazy
they've always realized those things the
[ __ ] anyway oh another ten that
guy's sling and dick he's the crested
that oh yeah crush banged everybody's
wife yeah yeah yep the friend I had a
friend who grew up in a cult in the
stories room oh yeah horrific I know the
friend I know we talked about yeah
horrific you know so you look at this
[ __ ] you like I don't [ __ ] dangerous
anytime someone is running any kind of
thing where they gotta separate you from
everybody else come to us I'm gonna get
you away from all those people it never
goes well
it [ __ ] it never goes well it never goes
well they want control they want control
and control of you and the best way to
do that is get you away from all these
other pesky people with all their
questions they don't know but we know we
know what's really going on we know what
this is really all about next thing you
know you're in a cult how many cults are
going on right now that we don't know
about it's like a gang of them that are
just like bubbling under the surface
that one they found out about last year
right that was a section New York net so
that's the real they throw them
[ __ ] in jail over that one yeah
the next someone is a weird one right
because it was a [ __ ] actors and actors
and actresses which does a sex cult
right they're all sex calls they should
stop saying sex cult right no sex cult
no sex cult it just looks like Buddhist
they're like they go okay yeah there we
go just think about that a guy
tells you he's God he won't [ __ ] your
wife like praising her way in the nose
right then she comes back the next day
smelling like [ __ ] and God knows what
else
look and you have to still respect the
guy and call him God yeah they do
yeah then such a sick sick [ __ ] mind
it's certain you have to be in such a
weak state as a human being I really buy
into that you can't call them you know
you can't quit they just for the [ __ ]
up weird state means maybe and they had
a void their life somewhere and this is
the way by filling it in I just I don't
see it
I can never join a cult well there's a
bunch of different things to get along
with the leader money mm-hmm you got I
saw your house yeah those people that
want to Jonestown have a saw that home
[Applause]